now two weeks ago the eu advised its
member states to consider barring
non-essential travel from the united
states since then several countries
including bulgaria and sweden have done
just that the eu first reopened its
borders to american tourists back in
june but the us decision not to do the
same in return remains a source of
frustration for governments and
businesses in europe
big river steel's new plant in the us
state of arkansas
it's considered one of the most modern
in the world it was a billion dollar
contract for german plant constructor
sms group
the keys to the works were only handed
over after the coronavirus pandemic hit
but a u.s travel ban on eu countries
early in the pandemic made the german
engineering company's work much more
difficult to complete
the us does make exceptions to the ban
in so-called national interest cases
but the mills of the country's
bureaucracy grind only very slowly
you only ever know at short notice if
our employees can get in on it
i have to make backup plans like how can
i cover with local people
how about hybrid meetings teams zoom and
the like
how can i work it that i've got enough
people there in the end it very much
complicates the business and as a result
makes things very difficult to plan
we will be suspended last year then
president trump closed u.s borders in
march europe had also closed its borders
down for a long time as it also tried to
get the pandemic under control
but in june of this year the eu opened
up again and allowed u.s citizens to
travel into the block without hindrance
for months business here has been hoping
the u.s would reciprocate
frustration in the engineering and plant
construction sector is
machines it's growing to install
machinery machines can't be serviced or
maintained
executives can't visit their
subsidiaries in the engineering sector
we have 1 800 subsidiaries in the us and
we can't travel to trade fairs either
which is important the us exhibition
season begins in the fall
video conferencing has its limits in any
business
for plant construction specialist sms
group though face-to-face meetings are
extremely important
especially when new contracts are
concerned
in the project business like ours where
negotiations can go on for days there's
always the opportunity in the evening to
meet or talk more informally
obviously that doesn't work at all at
video meeting distance you can talk
about technical issues but like i say
all the interpersonal exchange is
missing and often along with it the
capability of closing a deal
although some eu countries have
tightened entry restrictions again
vaccinated u.s citizens can still
generally enter the block
but business travelers in the other
direction we'll just have to call on
their reserves of patience for the time
being
well let's get more on that from our
financial correspondent in frankfurt
conrad booze and conrad is that patience
among european businesses wearing thin
now
good morning rob it's certainly wearing
thin among the people we just saw in the
video of course
there's no denying it even though i
think it's worth mentioning that so far
despite the travel restriction
the restrictions
the impact on our german manufacturer
manufacturing economy has been limited
so far you know the manufacturers here
in germany have been reporting constant
rises in production constant rises in
factory orders so despite of what we
heard in the video that business needs
presence obviously a lot of business has
been possible without business people
really meeting in person
is there any sign of the situation
between the eu and the us and and the
travel restrictions there
being an improving situation
no not really
no sign that i think is worth
giving out we've seen a lot of
statements that the americans want to do
something about the travel restrictions
you know when angela merkel recently
visited washington there was talk that
this would happen it did not
and you know the regulations in the us
are really absurd from some countries
you are allowed to travel into the
united states even though the countries
that you come from have some of the
highest
covet cases and also death rates all you
need is a test
then you're allowed to travel into the
united states malaysia for example sri
lanka is an example
you're allowed to travel to the u.s from
mexico by plane
the land border is still closed now how
does that make sense no the regulations
are really absurd and the political
divide between the republicans and the
democrats seems to be so strong that
it's impossible to predict what the
outcome will be
okay conrad boozen thank you